well after a hundred years of
championing the first amendment
democrats are now telling you that
censorship
is absolutely necessary to protect you
and their donors in big tech are happy
to oblige there's a lot of
violent rhetoric they're not censoring
though and that's kind of weird
david marcus of the federalists uh works
out of new york
has an amazing piece today in the new
york post describing
all the things they're not censoring and
it makes you wonder why
dave marcus joins us tonight to explain
dave thanks so much for coming on so
what did you find
well twitter claims that it has to
censor conservative voices and ban
president trump because they're in
violation of their safety guidelines
uh so i did about a 10 minute
search of twitter's own platform and
found
hashtags like kill trump assassinate
trump i found a user whose current name
is pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
a reference to killing police i found
examples of antifa using the platform to
help organize their riots so i
this only has to do with twitter trying
to silence
its critics and protect its interests
twitter doesn't care about the safety of
the american people the
the full comprehensive list of things
that twitter cares about
are its money and its power what's so
funny though
is this has been such a successful
tactic in pushing
professional conservatives the ones who
are supposed to be defending us back on
their heels
you know you can't believe what's on
parlor it's a cesspool of violence and
filth and they're like oh yeah i'm not
going to defend that
nobody says what you're saying which is
please it's the internet
there's a lot of garbage out there
doesn't mean you should censor people
no absolutely and the monopolistic
banning of parlor is really troublesome
this is so much worse than any monopoly
that we've seen before i mean
railroad barons and ma bell didn't have
a dark dystopian vision of the future
in which people were locked in their
houses staring at screens while machines
went burr
and brought them everything that they
needed and if that sounds familiar it's
because we just had a dress rehearsal of
it
and what the big tech oligarchs learned
is that a frightening number of the
american people
will simply sit down and take it and why
well because of safety
well and also they're anesthetized with
soma you know whedon netflix so it's
like it's it's totally fine like i'm i'm
comfort i'm comfy you know let it happen
but i i have to say it's hard and i'm
not a conspiracy
in any way but we just have had like
nine months of lockdowns that have made
people
increasingly dependent on digital
technology companies
and then it turns out they can withhold
the love if they want i mean maybe
there's no connection but it's kind of
amazing isn't it
there's absolutely a connection i mean
when twitter spent months and months
banning legitimate science that argued
against lockdowns and now
suddenly my brilliant governor andrew
cuomo has had this amazing revelation
that oh
maybe lockdowns hurt people i you know
there's clearly a connection i mean
there's a connection to them burying
the new york post hunter biden story to
undermine an election
all of these decisions operate again in
their own
interests and my message to twitter ceo
jack dorsey is that
he may be a billionaire and and he may
be frolicking on yachts with with
beyonce and jay-z
i'm just a journalist but there's
millions of americans like me who are
not going to sit back and just take this
that's totally right and i you know i
have to say i hate to judge people's
parenting it's very hard to be a parent
hard to take your kids to a restaurant
but the next time i see parents with
little kids
staring at an ipad in a restaurant you
know if you walk by and a kid was like
tugging on a winston you'd say yeah
you're probably a little young to be
smoking right
but kids let their i mean kids are
allowed by their parents to get
completely addicted to this garbage this
poison and nobody says anything
yeah absolutely sorry i lost control
dave marcus great to see you tonight
thank you for your sober analysis and
your reporting